I want to play this little clip from uh
Gensler the the video that he put out
after the Kraken action uh that has been
kind of circulating especially among
what you might describe as the Bitcoin
maximalists uh I I want to play this and
get your reaction because they are
saying that this this validates the view
that uh you know it's it's Bitcoin and
self-custody are the only way to go um
so let's just play this real quick and
get your reaction no not your keys not
your crypto you see you're basically an
investor in their platform if it goes
under and we've seen plenty of that
recently you end up in line in the
bankruptcy court that's why it's so
important that these companies and
platforms comply with the Securities Law
so you know it's the point there is that
uh you know Gensler is you know quoting
the famous not your keys not not your
crypto line and that is kind of uh
validating the idea that you really
shouldn't even have your your crypto on
an exchange if you want you know total
security and sovereignty what do you
make of that Nick
yeah I mean I agree obviously you know
we invest heavily in startups that help
people self-custody their coins so I
clearly support that crypto only works
if people have some self-custody because
otherwise we give all the power back to
the intermediaries and we haven't
accomplished anything because then the
government can co-opt the intermediaries
and use them as they will
however I'm also pragmatic and I
recognize that exchanges will exist
there's demand for their services we
can't do everything in a non-custodial
way
um so the and there's a whole set of
allocators that will need centralized
touch points to custody of their coins
to trade on them Etc the decentralized
infrastructure
isn't the totality of the industry and
it will never be so in my view the
challenge is to improve the exchanges
that do exist and pressure them to be as
accountable as possible which is why I'm
an advocate of proof of reserves for
instance
regarding like whether it validates
Bitcoin maximalism I mean staking can be
done self-custodally it can be done on
your own even there's actually you know
Services allow you to stake if you don't
want to stake yourself you still kind of
retain access to your coins but you're
relying on a more sophisticated pool
that will help you do it which is not a
Securities transaction in my opinion
Kraken may have left themselves open to
that allegation in terms of the
structure of I think that is I'm
actually sympathetic to the SEC in that
particular instance but there's
certainly ways to stake even as a retail
individual who's not very sophisticated
about the technology or anything there's
ways to Outsource that to others which
don't render it a security so I don't
see it as vindicating Bitcoin maximalism
you know in in either direction or or uh
yeah so it you know staking ultimately
will be more decentralized by virtue of
the fact that Kraken is out of the
business of doing it uh just a comment
from Bitcoin motorists writing in from
YouTube saying I just buy Bitcoin I
don't stake should I care about any of
this and I mean I guess the answer is if
you don't own your if you don't own your
keys or you don't have your keys you
should be worried about it regardless of
whether or not you're staking right
I think you should care that the SEC is
harassing the exchanges
um a lot of people you know that may
think that they're totally insulated
from that they still have some Reliance
on an exchange as an on and off ramp we
do need these touch points with banks
and with the you know traditional
Financial system we'll always need that
we don't have a perfectly peer-to-peer
economy of Bitcoin that I'm not even
sure that's really possible so yeah I
mean I'm concerned that the SEC is going
after a kraken in particular has been
one of the most reputable and successful
exchanges
um and you know I'd be concerned if
they're going after coinbase too even if
you don't agree with everything coinbase
does or everything Kraken does we still
do need these credible intermediaries
you said that you you do have some
sympathy for the SEC in in this
particular Kraken case and you also
mentioned earlier that you you know part
of the red flags with FTX for you was
that they were offshore
presumably that the red flag was that
they're not complying with U.S
regulation so you know what are the
Realms that you see regulation being
appropriate for the crypto space and
where should they just the government
just be you know completely hands off
yeah great question I mean I don't think
that
um a no regulation world is is the best
because clearly the crypto industry has
failed to self-regulate I think you
could ask exchanges to do proof of
Reserve
um that's similar in some ways to
um having oversight uh over uh you know
I I would say it's actually more of a
substitute for a really aggressive
top-down uh regulatory stance
um I think asking exchanges to segregate
client and operating capital
in an accounting and a literal sense
um is completely the right way if you
look at nydfs they had guidance recently
that they published asking for that
segregation asking a privilege client
deposits in the case of liquidation I
totally agree with that
um you know it doesn't make sense for
clients of exchanges to be really
subordinate Junior creditors in the case
of bankruptcy there you should have a
trust style product in the name of the
client such that they're insulated in
the case of bankruptcy or something like
that so you know those are really Common
Sense things that I think should exist
aside from that I think
you know I well other domains were
regulated regulation is warranted would
be a kind of a Securities Law framework
where we allowed to bring Tok we were
able to bring tokens into concert with
Securities Law through some disclosure
framework that was fit for purpose the
way we have a disclosure firmware for
equities the things you need to disclose
are different so we will need a revised
framework however the administration is
not implied anything or suggested that
they might want to do that so that's
more of sort of a wish list item but I
don't think it'll happen anytime soon
this idea of digital cash being you know
one of the fundamental propositions of
cryptocurrency uh what is for people who
might be watching this who are curious
about cryptocurrency but they're not
steeped in it like you are could you
just make the the big picture case for
why you think this industry is thriving
and or you know why it's grown so much
in a relatively short span and what is
the like what's the point of it what why
is digital the idea of digital cash good
and necessary and why is decentralized
finance
um a good thing well there's two main
things that
um two main Trends basically the crypto
people it's a broad tent are fighting
against they're trying to restore one is
there's a sound money contingent so
basically believing that we should
reinstitute a monetary system that has
less discretion and so that's a
rebellion against the waves of credit
that are created with basically
discretionary monetary policy that's a
long discussion of course so that's a
big part of it
the second is a push to restore
transactional privacy that has been
eroded since really the 70s since
Finance was digitized
that's and since um you know
intermediaries have been more empowered
and there have been a specific number of
legal cases especially the third party
doctrine that meant that Financial
privacy has been effectively eliminated
in the U.S and a lot of us identify this
as a very dangerous trend
um and they're trying to push back at it
so defy and stable coins uh and of
course Bitcoin are attempts to restore
something which we once had which was
Financial autonomy and the freedom to
transact without asking the state for
permission hey thanks for watching that
excerpt from our live conversation with
SEC commissioner Hester purse and crypto
investor and writer Nick Carter about
the government's escalating Crackdown on
cryptocurrency exchanges like Kraken and
the broader defy economy join me and
nicolespie here every Thursday at 1 pm
Eastern for more conversations like this
and subscribe to Reasons YouTube channel
for notifications whenever our videos go
live
thanks for watching